c'est trop facile
on n'arrête pas de prendre des décisions
des décisions qui nous emmène d'un jour
à l'autre
ces décisions qu'ils ne modifient qu'à
peine le cours des choses
et puis il ya les autres des si j'ai
décroché un vrai job à mon humble avis
tu pètes 1 kg aucune envie de devenir
loser et de faire ça toute ma vie
[Musique]
est-ce que ça va
je suis là pour fo cambriolé bakool vous
essayez vous suicidez
vous envers la porte en sortant
t'aurais pu barrer appelé les flics non
c'est quoi le protocole quand on a
failli mourir et c'est quoi ton plan
maintenant tu vas rester là à me
surveiller ses s'attendre on croirait
vraiment que j'ai un plan qu'est-ce
qu'on peut avaler après une tentative de
suicide aux médicaments
c'est bon je vais manger hawk et aidez
vous maintenant tous les deux
je te jure que je tue est ok et rien de
ce que tu feras ou de ce que tu diras ne
pourra m'empêcher non c'est faux et est
très égoïste à part de me retenir
oui c'est un mais des faux
[Musique]
je crois vraiment que tu tentes je suis
certain que tu peux trouver le bonheur
[Musique]
je dois avoir l'air ridicule
non tu as dit son temps
pourquoi est-ce que tu tiens moi
j'en ai aucune idée
je pense qu'au fond tant de continuer
on y arrive
[Musique]
alors à quoi ça rime ce
déjà
[Musique]